Are you male, 30 +, and still not hitched?
If you think that life begins at 30 for a man -...
...that good men, like good wine, age well - then it's time to think ahead.
Although marriage isn't out of the question,...
...what lies ahead is no easy road.
The time when men who possessed the three "H's"...
...-Height, High income, and High level of education - were seen as hot properties are gone.
Women aren't interested in workaholic men trying to raise their professional value.
A recent survey revealed that 70% of the thirtysomething men want to get married.
However, with each passing year, it's going to be increasingly difficult.
Surprisingly, women in their 20s are especially harsh in their appraisal of men...
...who have remained single well into their 30s.
Here're a few typical comments:...
"If a guy's over 30 and still living with his parents,...
...people are going to be saying that he's a mama's boy."
"There's a single guy in my office who's 37,...
...but I bet he frequents the sex trade, so it's repulsive for me even to sit next to him."
"A 36 - year - old in the accounting department is kind of creepy...
...because he just seems like someone who has absolutely no sex drive."
Men may say, "he's a good guy anyway,"...
...but women aren't charitable in assessing a man's value as a potential mate.
The harsh reality for 30 + men is the possibility of single-handedly caring for aging parents,...
...perhaps even having to quit his work.
Even without ailing parents,...
...a single man must still save a large amount of money for retirement.
And then he'll face a long and lonely time until at last, life retires from him.